die meldungen verdichten sich es scheint
in diesem jahr einen wirklich riesiges
bienensterben in europa zu geben
wir bekommen so langsam die folgen
unseres handelns ganz konkret zu spüren
welche das sind und warum das große
sterben dieses jahr einsetzt dass jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction und uhr
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vereinzelt poppen dieser tage die
meldung auf aber es scheint
tragischerweise ein sehr deutlicher
trend für seinen brandenburg 40 prozent
der bienenvölker sind nicht durch den
winter gekommen seit zehn jahren habe so
große verluste nicht mehr gegeben meldet
die berliner morgenpost
deutschlandweit rechnet der deutsche
imkerbund sogar mit dem tod der hälfte
der bienen in diesem winter 170 tausend
bienenvölker haben den winter wohl nicht
überlebt aus vorarlberg in österreich
werden sogar bis zu 70 prozent gemeldet
hobby imker michael meier aus
oberösterreich hat dieses bild auf
facebook gepostet sein statement dazu
so schaut es dann aus wenn alle meine
bienen im frühjahr tot am boden liegen
umgebracht von umweltgiften die von
chemischen konzernen stammt und von
sklaven bauern verspritzt werden und von
einer milbe die aus asien eingeschleppt
wurde
wenn die biene stirbt stirbt der mensch
wir können geld nicht essen michael
meier hat recht wenn er als
hauptursachen die aus asien
eingeschleppte varroamilbe und einflüsse
durch chemischen pflanzenschutz benennt
aber auch fehlende nahrung für die
bienen und der klimawandel sind wichtige
gründe wien gibt es her seit 125
millionen jahren auf der erde sie kommen
mit den erhöhten temperaturen einfach
nur schlecht zurecht und auch seine
schlussfolgerung ist nicht von der hand
zu weisen den bienen sterben von zwölf
menschen sterben es wird der körper
dankt eine hungerkatastrophe in europa
geben aber die folgen wären dramatisch
sein obst und rapp werden dieses jahr
weniger beschreibt und wir werden die
erträge sinken prognostiziert der
deutsche imkerbund und natürlich wird es
weniger honig geben und er wird deutlich
teurer
bienen bestäuben 80 prozent der wild und
nutzpflanzen die folgen eines
aussterbens der bienen oder der
halbierung der bienenvölker sind
katastrophal und in deutschland haben
sich die bienenvölker von 25 millionen
152 auf weniger
eine million heute halbiert die
wissenschaftler rechnen mit 1,42
millionen toten jährlich durch das
aussterben der bienen und rund 700.000
wenn sich die bienenvölker weltweit
halbieren es muss also dringend
gehandelt werden mehr bioanbau weniger
pflanzenschutzmittel mehr nahrung für
bienen zb durch wildblumen an den
feldrändern konsequente bekämpfung der
varroa-milbe und natürlich das vorgehen
gegen den klimawandel wie gesagt das
sind die ersten meldungen
wir halten euch auf dem laufenden damit
er nichts verpasst auch zum
bienensterben hier klicken und mehr ein
abo aufs auge drücken und nicht
vergessen mir einen auf die glocke zu
geben hier geht es zur best of klicks
und playlist darauf klicken und dann
gibt's nur das beste vom krieg ziehen
wenn er weitere infos zum bienensterben
2017 findet schreibt sie unten in die
kommentare diskutiert die lage und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran